des porsche rutilante une alpine
impeccable ou des renault d'exception la
vente aux enchères du all-star garage a
rassemblé cent dix sept lots de voitures
et de motos de collection et parmi eux
une ferrari pas comme les autres la
superstar de ces enchères a fait son
apparition sous le feu des projecteurs
de la nouvelle émission de philippe
lellouche
comme un hommage à son premier
propriétaire jean philippe smet alias
johnny hallyday 12 cylindres à plat 96
mille kilomètres au compteur et des
souvenirs pleins la carrosserie après
des débuts plutôt timides les prix
s'envolent milliers parmi les unes des
plus belles enchères qu'on ait plus
aucun des pubs mais comme des conduites
jusqu'à présent parce que ça commençait
à se battre à 160 milles jusqu'à 170
mille donc c'est quelque chose où 2000
en mille de 2000 en 2000 on a vécu un
grand moment
on a vécu un très grand en préfinale
270000 euros
le propriétaire de 7 512 tr 94 ancien
avocat du chanteur c'est avant tout
l'histoire de la voiture qui a fait
monter les enchères
c'est un moment un peu émouvant parce
que moi je venais vendre une ferrari
avec un petit plus parce qu'elle avait
parties nulles à mon client et ami très
proche quand même en vain et puis
brusquement je m'aperçois que à mon
corps je suis a pas beaucoup à défendre
mais sans vraiment l'avoir rue j'ai
vendu le souvenir validés parce que la
personne qui est cette voiture que je
connaîtrai peut-être un jour c'est
forcément un fan de l'idée plus qu'un
fan de ferrari la voiture ça ne me fait
rien le celui de lille est ce autre
chose qu'on n'oublie pas
pour cause de crise sanitaire seulement
25 acheteurs étaient présents mais le
site un terrain chez qualcomm diffuser
en direct la vente et c'est environ 1300
personnes connectées dont leur nouveau
propriétaire de cette ferrari
extraordinaire